you're about to meet conscience sing and
today is the most important day of her
life as a cat entrepreneur conscience to
open crumbs and whiskers a cafe in
Washington DC that serves coffee
pastries and adoptable cats all under
the same roof she's got the ambition the
backing and the cats to make it happen
that's why she's on her way to the
city's office of Zoning to find out if
the city will make a special exemption
that allows her to open for business
I've kind of been in love with animals
pretty much my entire life and my second
love is business I love business and
eventually I was like man can I combine
animals in business and I was like
probably not that sounds horrible let's
not do that you know a few months ago I
was in Thailand and I was backpacking
and I found a cat cafe you know I
started thinking immediately about how
something like that could totally be
brought to DC which is where I live so
contra actually approached the
Washington Humane Society with this
awesome idea we were very very excited
about it on multiple levels first of all
it's a cat cafe in DC who can not be
excited about that the Department of
Health is was of course opposed because
in the food code combining animals and
food is simply illegal so when I called
them and told them the idea they were
just like no we're not even going to
have this conversation and the concerns
of course with animals are ordered like
are you gonna stink up the neighborhood
noise you know waste and sanitation I
almost gave up actually in the beginning
because when I heard I had to get a
zoning exemption I called an animal
warning facility and I said hey how much
should i budget just for zoning he said
$25,000 and I was like I was like just
for zoning he was like yeah nothing else
just zoning and I was like oh my god I'm
going to give up what do you get when
you pair cats with coffee a cat cafe of
course just as conscient was giving up
the news media stepped in and otherwise
respectable journalists did what they do
best
they went bonkers for another story
about cats
Washington City Paper even fouetté
conscience file at the DC Department of
Health the city's internal emails
revealed a series of institutional
delays and non responses with her
business plans on paws conscient
prepared for yet another big expense we
also have not just state-of-the-art
equipment that we need we also have
lawyers and lawyers are really expensive
having sunk her personal savings into
crumbs and whiskers conscient turned to
Kickstarter that's when she learned the
cataclysmic power of combining the
internet with things that are cute in
three hours we erased ten thousand
dollars we launched the campaign to the
world at around 6:30 and when I was
going to bed that night at like 11:00
we'd had like 11.5 K and the next
afternoon we were past our call and I
was like what just to happen but we know
that what we are going to have to do is
have a partner because there's no way
really we can sustain a cafe according
to the food code by ourselves
armed with legal counsel a kettle of
kick starter cash and an endless supply
of adoptable cats conscient was ready to
face the Zoning Board their final
decision came later that day
it took a lot of work but crumbs and
whiskers finally opens tomorrow and the
future of DC's first cat cafe is now in
the hands of conscience Inge and cat
fanatics across the nation's capital